so you know it's like super cool like
really cool dude
joining the army
you want to know how oh you you don't
think it's cool i mean i guess if you
want to buy overpriced cars at 29
interest and engage in domestic violence
sure uh
don't forget the fat wife oh i hit my
wife but i have ptsd so i just blame the
fireworks what are you a cop
so
[Laughter]
so you don't think it's cool wait till
you see this cool commercial
who will build tomorrow
[Music]
the code fighter yeah
the chef the virus hunter no there's a
chef though
uh this is the wavelength
the replenisher that's the chef
the groundbreaker the baby killer
the wife beater
the alcohol liquid post-traumatic stress
the homeless guy at every overpass yes
oh [ __ ] hey why don't you get the code
breaker to work on that [ __ ]
va uh wait time on the phone jesus
christ
the security guard that failed his
police psych exam
[Laughter]
the va administrator
[Music]
down out there
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] join the army today and get one
free painting from george w
bush of a dog or a basket fruit
sorry you lost your legs
that's right what happens when these
five heroes
rise up and band together uh half a
million iraqi civilians die
somebody says the guy who graduated high
school with a 2.0 gpa
the poppy field defender
the afghani warlord bodyguard
the oil derricks employee
[ __ ] i love this the private contractor
the i did it because i needed money for
college guy
the i'm gonna milk this for the rest of
my life with bumper stickers and free
denny's meals guy
oh [ __ ] um
you know eventually you could have you
could do be a dan crenshaw type
it takes a lot though you have to level
up as they say
yes exactly
anyway um the israeli puppet
pop pop
oh [ __ ] the pat tillman yeah the former
football player
the vaccine distributor
the inauguration defender
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this saudi mall cop
somebody's coming
the saudi mall cops very funny it's
actually very good
that's very very oh [ __ ] the lying
sniper
[Laughter]
little chris kyle references
the pathological sniper
and then there's just a picture of
madison they're like and the human meme
that's all he is he's just a meme the
fema detention specialist jason
oh [ __ ] okay come on enough
they're heroes you're right all right
this is
look are you did you not see the cool
video did you not see how cool these
heroes are
the fat chick from motor pool
[Music]
the desert queen
[Laughter]
the gunny who has twice as many
batteries for his optics as you do
the it's okay i'm on suboxone now guy
and don't forget mister can't we let the
marines go in
first
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we're gonna get a lot of [ __ ]
for this one oh yeah
you guys are [ __ ] heroes dude
relax they're not firefighters
all right somebody talks to chris goes
okay you know
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the puerto rican cook monster tiger says
i did eight years in the marine corps
and this is making my size
jesus you guys really make me feel like
the service meant nothing
[Laughter]
then we've done our jobs
oh [ __ ] joy of pessy just won i think
the suicide statistic
oh god we're just goofing
i'm just joking there's a new book a
little new book going on around here
come on we uh we respect all the the
troops and stuff
thank you for your service
[Laughter]
all right enough
but how did the cocaine get to america
mike exactly
all right heroes i guess is my point the
frank lucas
pretty good it's pretty good all right
we're done we're done right
the child support specialist i like that
one
enough we're done all right
good you know somebody said sorry
the predatory lone hunter yes
all right now we're done this is what
look then we're not running the bit into
the ground look i'm moving over to a
different screen
we have moved over we are done okay